Alright Michael.
>> So.
>> You think you got an answer?
>> Yeah. It's interesting. So I guess it
really does make some intuitive sense that the
line is really, really nailed down by the
points close to it. And the points that are
far away from it, really don't have any
influence. So I would put non zero, sorry, I
would put zero alphas on the lower left
hand minus and the, one of the upper pluses.
>> Yes, and, you know, I haven't actually worked out the answer here.
But, both of these pluses probably don't matter.
Certainly, this one doesn't. certainly, this minus doesn't
matter. Maybe this one doesn't matter, either. But
the point that she raises, is exactly right. The,
the points that are far away from the
decision boundary, and can't be used to define
the contours of that decision boundary. Don't matter,
whether they're plus or minus. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, cool.
>> Does this remind you of anything?
>> Nearest neighbors?
>> That's almost always the answer. Why
does it remind you of nearest neighbors?
>> because only the local points matter?
>> Oh, that's a good answer. I was going to
have a different answer. Know what my answer was?
>> What?
>> It's like KNN except that you already
done the work of figuring out which points actually
matter. So you don't have to keep all of them. You can throw away some of them.
>> Oh, I see. So it doesn't just take the nearest ones, it actually
does this complicated quadratic program to figure
out which ones are actually going to contribute.
>> Right, so it's just another way of thinking
about instance-based learning, except that rather than
being completely lazy, you put a lot,
some energy into figuring out which points
you could actually stand to throw away.
>> Interesting.
>> Okay. Yeah, I think that's kind of interesting. I think it's kind of
cool. So good. So you got that. Well let me show you one more thing,
Michael. Alright, so you got this notion of there being very few of the, the
support vectors that you need, but I
want to point out something very important about
some of the parameters in this equation. So
we just got through talking about the alphas,
right? Basically the alphas say, pay attention to
this data point or not. But if you look
carefully at this equation, the only place where the xs come into play with one
another is here. So Michael, generally speaking,
given a couple of vectors, what does xi transpose xj actually mean?
>> It's the dot product.
>> Right, and what is the dot product?
>> It's like the projection of one of those onto the other right?
>> Yeah, and that ends up giving you what?
>> A number.
>> Yes. Does that number kind of represent anything? And if you
say the dot product, I will climb through the screen and kill you.
>> What about the length of the projection.
>> Right, and what does that kind of represent for you?
>> Well, I guess in particular if the x's are,
well if there are five going to each
other than it's going to be zero. But if they
kind of point in the same direction, they're going to be,
it's going to be a large value, and if they
put in opposite directions it's going to be a negative
value. So it's sort of kind of indicating how
much they're pointing in the same direction. So, I
guess it could be a measure of their similarity.
>> Rightl, I think that is, that is exactly right. This is the kind of
a notion of similarity. So if you look at this equation, what it basically says.
Find all pairs of points. Figure out which ones matter
for, for defining your decision boundry. And then think about how
they relate to one another in terms of their output
labels. With respect to how similar they are to one another.